Petit rajout des familles, je vous rappelle que je joue le 29 octobre à Paris et vous avez été un peu dingues,
Il y a 91 % des places qui sont déjà réservés je vous mets un lien dans la description si vous voulez venir.
Je pense que dans quelques jours il y en a plus.
Voilà merci vous êtes au top et on va se marrer. Salut ! Vous souvenez peut-être qu'il y a quasiment un an c'est-à-dire en novembre de
l'année dernière je vous avez parlé d'une énigme pour trouver un trésor de 50 000 euros.
Déjà le départ il fait plaisir. Et le projet pour trouver ce trésor c'était de résoudre onze énigmes qui sont elles mêmes contenues dans un
livre et le trésor est enterré quelque part en France.
Et là franchement, ça te donne envie de sortir une pelle !
J'avais soutenu ce projet dès le départ c'est ce qu'on appelle un coup de pouce
Je le rappelle mes vidéos "coup de pouce" ce ne sont pas des
partenariats sur lequel j'ai un intérêt c'est juste un coup de pouce pour un projet que je trouve cool et bien le livre ça y
est elle est sorti aux éditions du trésor ça c'est la version collector que j'ai reçue pour avoir participé au kisskissbankbank.
Et ça c'est la version normale qu'on trouve en librairie alors je les ai contacté pour que vous puissiez en gagner un, mais pour le gagner
nous vous avons concocté les éditions du trésor et moi même une petite énigme des familles à résoudre. Je leur ai dit que ce qui serait cool c'est qu'on
fasse une énigme sur les cinq sens, et eux ils m'ont répondu: "Ouais ouais ouais par un ordinateur les cinq sens."
Bien joué, mais nous on va partir en fait...
Bon on a bossé et on a réussi à la créer cette énigme. La règle du jeu est très simple il ya cinq sens donc cinq
énigmes la réponse à ces cinq énigmes ça va vous donner une question et il faudra répondre à la question. Pour être très précis il faudra
répondre à ça sur Twitter,
mais je vous explique tout ça dans la description plutôt que de vous le raconter. Alors les cinq sens tout le monde les connaît on
les apprend depuis tout petit à la maternelle mais il y a d'autres sens d'ailleurs dont on parle jamais, comme le sens de l'orientation
comme le sens qui permet aussi de savoir s'il fait chaud ou s'il fait froid, mais on va se concentrer sur les cinq sens classiques:
la vue, le goût, l'ouïe, l'odorat, et le toucher
Alors pourquoi les cinq sens ? Parce que justement ils sont souvent intimement liés avec les énigmes.
Ils ont un lien très fort avec les messages secrets où les messages codés, par exemple savez-vous ce qu'est la sténographie ? Non ?
Ben écoutez je vais vous le dire ! [imitation Sarkozy]
Je le perds de plus en plus mon Sarko ! La sténographie c'est l'art de dissimuler un message de le cacher ça vient du grec "steganos"
qui veut dire "couvert" ou "couvrir" et de "graph" qui veut dire "message". Pas du tout ! Ca veut dire
"écriture", "graff" en grec. Et ça n'a rien à voir avec la cryptographie qui elle est plus l'art du secret
puisqu'elle cherche à rendre un message incompréhensible en le modifiant. C'est différents ! On passe donc aux 5 énigmes dont les 5
réponses je vous rappelle vont former une question. Et la réponse,
à cette question, sera donc la réponse à l'énigme. Donc toujours dans la sténographie et puisqu'une image vaut mieux qu'un long discours,
voici une application réelle. Vous voyez en ce moment même un message d'apparence complètement anodine pourtant si vous regardez bien certaines lettres sont légèrement
différentes, ce qui, une fois remise dans l'ordre devrait en temps normal former un mot ou avoir l'air de former un mot...
Enfin bref, cherchez vous pouvez mettre pause parce qu'on va passer tout de suite à la suite !
Et la suite c'est le toucher, alors c'est pas facile facile de vouloir faire une énigme sur le toucher en vidéo sur YouTube.
Ben non... Moi je peux essayer de vous toucher,
mais à part dégueulasser ma caméra je ne sais pas ce que je suis en train de faire là, ou alors faudrait que tu te frottes toi
aussi contre l'écran en même temps. Le corps humain est assez incroyable, parce que parfois pour compenser la perte d'un sens le corps va
développer d'une manière parfois incroyable l'un des autres sens. C'est pourquoi les non-voyants
ont parfois une ouïe ou un touché beaucoup plus développé que nous. L'image que vous êtes en train de voir actuellement est
l'énigme du toucher, avec cette façon un petit peu bizarre de faire un ciel étoilé mais attention
ce n'est peut-être pas ce que vous pensez... et si je vous disais justement pour vous aider
que vous feriez mieux de vous faire aider par un non voyant. Il arriverait plus facilement que vous à résoudre l'énigme du mois à l'interpréter.
Encore une fois je vous laisse faire pause le temps de chercher
je vous mettrai aussi ces images en lien dans la description pour que vous puissiez les imprimer si vous voulez.
Et bien passons à la troisième c'est à dire l'odorat. Hein ? [reniflements]
Est-ce-que c'est vrai que les que les youtubers ne se lavent pas avant de faire les vidéos ?
FAUX ! C'est pas copyrighter ça, "faux" en vidéo ?
On va plutôt faire un voyage dans l'univers des nez et des grands noms de la parfumerie. Les nez sont les personnes qui créent et les parfums.
Au tout départ on a inventé les parfums pour camoufler, pour
dissimuler une odeur, une mauvaise odeur et en
particulier les gants et les éventails, donc au tout départ le métier de parfumeur était plutôt associé aux métiers de gantier. Dans quelques instants je
vais vous lire un petit texte dans ce texte il va falloir que vous retrouviez les villes auxquelles je fais référence.
Vous devrez comprendre le chemin et retenir les initiales des directions empruntées, par exemple "N" pour
nord et "SO" pour le sud ouest etc, et vous obtiendrez ainsi un mot de quatre lettres.
[lis le texte]
Et voilà encore une fois vous retrouverez le texte dans la description en lien. Avant dernière énigme: le goût !
Encore une fois inutile d'essayer de lécher votre écran ! C'est pas terrible, tu peux essayer si ça te fait kiffé, vraiment je t'en prie.
Au final, on vous a plutôt préparer une bonne salade de lettres, ça ressemble un petit peu à une charade
rien à voir avec charal, puisqu'on est sur une salade.
[lis le texte]
Voilà encore de quoi vous stimuler et maintenant passons à la cinquième et dernière énigme.
La cinquième et dernière énigme si vous avez bien suivi c'est l'ouïe, et vous vous souvenez de ce qu'on s'est dit
lors de la première énigme sur la sténographie ?
L'art de cacher des messages dans des images, et bien il y à une variante à ça: on peut très bien cacher des messages dans des éléments sonores.
Vous avez perçu forcément des sons tout au long de cette vidéo
il y a de fortes chances qu'ils aient un sens. Et des codes secrets
avec des bruits très courts ou des bruits très longs, j'en connais pas énormément.
On arrive donc à 5 énigmes sur lesquelles vous allez trouver 5 mots ce qui va vous donner une
question à laquelle vous allez devoir trouver une réponse.
Accessoirement les cinq mots sont dans le désordre
il faut quand même recréér la question vous même. Je ferai le tirage au sort sur Twitter d'ici une bonne semaine
je vais mettre un tweet qui est dédié à ça il faudra y répondre. Je vous explique tout ça dans la description. Comme d'habitude pensez à
liker la vidéo et surtout à vous abonner et puis je vous donne rendez vous le 22
à 15H pour la prochaine vidéo où je vais mentaliser quelqu'un ça va être assez rigolo, quelqu'un que vous connaissez.
Mais surtout j'ai une très très très très
à l'énorme en fait j'ai un truc à vous dire et ça je vous le dit dans la vidéo du
22 à 15H. Bonne recherche, gagnez les 50000 euros !
Ciao !
Alors ça c'est bien que ce soit sur votre téléphone votre tablette ou votre ordinateur,
vous pouvez cliquer sur le petit cercle là, oui juste là avec mon visage
et si ça se trouve il y a les 50000 euros derrière. Ou un petit peu...
Moi, je dis il vaut mieux cliquer quand même clique c'est bien !